you all know what's happening what i  thought i would escape this in my career  because i didn't go through local news  so i never had to cover punxsutawney  phil oh i have covered it  i have covered him yeah we need to find  one of those clips and play it in the  eye closer on friday  we have some breaking news i can't  believe i'm saying this we have some  breaking news from groundhog day from  gobbler's knob home of puck's attorney  phil  did the famous groundhog see a shadow  this morning did he did he did he  he did he did which means we will have  six more weeks of winter according to  folklore when phil sees a shadow winter  does not end early gail brings back  memories does phil even know that he's  phil  i may just pull up something it's a very  existential question did you see your  shadow i don't think he knows that those  are all real beards  he doesn't know what's going on  [Laughter]  only but i like the tradition of it